la pomme plus précisément c'est une
association des papas de la martinique
c'est une association qui a pour objet
de valoriser valoriser le papa de
défendre les papas dans les eaux droit
de coparentalité parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte depuis bien longtemps que les que
les papas n'ont pas bonne presse en
martinique et on s'est surtout rendu
compte que là les pratiques avaient
changé ont changé les pratiques ont
changé mais les mentalités n'ont pas
bougé
aujourd'hui quand on se promène devant
les écoles devant les crèches dans les
parcs à fort de france en fin d'année
dans les villes on se rend bien compte
qu'on compte souvent des papas
accompagnés de l'enfant et mais les
mentalités n'ont pas changé et on
continue à 10 ans a à faire passer le
message que les papas ne s'occupe pas de
l'enfant qui font des enfants et qui
s'en vont et qu'ils ne s'en occupe pas
et la plupart du temps quand il ya des
problèmes
quand il ya des problèmes avec des
enfants on considère que c'est que c'est
à cause des papas nous ce qu'on est en
train de mettre en place si des ateliers
si des ateliers pour pour faire en sorte
que dès que des enfants qui ont vécu ce
sont les européens et dpa qui ont qui
n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas besoin qu'ils
n'ont pas pu s'occuper ou qui n'ont pas
voulu un peu importe s'occuper d'un
enfant puisse se rencontrer et discuter
des raisons qui ont fait qu'ils n'ont
pas pu qui n'ont pas pu vivre ensemble
qui n'ont pas bu vivre les choses qu'ils
auraient dû vivre ensemble qui n'ont pas
pu qui n'ont pas pu le faire et donc
voilà ça c'est déjà décédé et en fait
nous aussi ce qu'on est moins c'est
mettre en synergie ce qui se fait déjà
on n'a pas pour vocation de réinventer
quoi que ce soit il ya plein de choses
qui se disent qu'ils sont une chose qui
se font il ya plein d'associations qui
font déjà des choses qui font les autres
dit jose pour les parents pour les
enfants et on est moins mais tous en
synergie et faire en sorte que
que les choses fonctionnent mieux alors
seaway aujourd'hui la papam c'est une
petite pierre qu'on essaie de mettre à
l'édifice à cet édifice et on se
conseille aussi rendu compte que à aucun
moment le papa le père l'homme n'était
dans cette équation
donc on veut aujourd'hui que le ps soit
l'équation pouvoir résoudre des
problèmes de la société faut savoir
qu'il ya beaucoup de papas qui sont
privés de l'enfant pour des raisons
multiples et variés et que parfois c'est
simplement ils sont privés les enfants
simplement due par une décision
unilatérale de la maman qui décide que
l'enfant n'ira pas chez son papa pour
des raisons parce que parfois on confond
relation de couple est elle assurée par
an et on fait on fait enfin en fait un
espèce d'amalgamé avec les deux et à
partir du moment qu'on est plus on coupe
on considère que la parentalité
disparaît ce qui n'est pas ce qui ne
devrait pas être le cas